Speaker 1: We have updated vaccine polling
data from Monmouth University, we now know
that roughly one in five Americans still do
not want the covid vaccine.
And those numbers are heavily and significantly
led by Republicans, 43 percent of whom still
do not want the covid vaccine and do not plan
to get it.
If they can avoid it, I guess if they can
avoid it suggests something about if it became
a requirement for a job or to do something
they want to do, maybe they would get it.
Overall, the good news is that the number
who don't want the vaccine is down, but it's
not really down dramatically.
Earlier in the pandemic, we saw significant
reductions in vaccine hesitancy is really
leveling out.
Now, the numbers are stunningly partizan.
If you look at numbers by party, 43 percent
of Republicans do not want the vaccine, 22
percent of independents do not want the vaccine,
and just five percent of Democrats do not
want the vaccine.
If it were all Democrats, we would get to
herd immunity.
If it were all independents, we might it would
be 78 percent do.
And if it were up to only Republicans, if
everybody believe what Republicans believe,
we would not get to herd immunity, although
maybe eventually we would, because so many
of them would get sick that they develop natural
immunity.
That's a different story, though.
Many would die in that process.
Now, also interesting is that the racial gap
seems to almost have completely gone away,
at least according to this poll, 22 percent
of whites and 20 percent of people of color
don't want the vaccine.
That is now essentially statistically equal.
There was a point in time at which there was
more of a gap led by vaccine hesitancy among
the black American community.
So the big takeaway is.
If 80 percent of the country plans to get
vaccinated, we can actually reach something
approximating approximating herd immunity,
which medical science believes.
Again, it depends on how contagious is, whatever
variant becomes dominant and how sort of homogenous
versus heterogenous is vaccination.
Somewhere between 70 and 85 percent vaccination
would be required to achieve herd.
However, one thing we have to remember is
that vaccine opposition is not homogenous.
It varies greatly in different parts of the
country.
The Mississippi, Missouri, Massachusetts gap
right now is a really good example.
92 percent of those in Massachusetts want
the vaccine.
Mississippi is already at the point where
tons of vaccination appointments are going
unfilled.
Demand is lagging.
So you could end up with a situation where
some states are sort of extra vaccinated well
beyond what's required for herd immunity and
other states never reach it.
And you have constant small clusters and outbreaks
which will just extend the pandemic.
The sad part is that because some people don't
develop immunity, even when you get vaccinated,
remember the 95 percent effective vaccine,
some others can't get the vaccine because
of specific medical conditions.
You will have a situation where those who
could get it but just choose not to will give
the virus to some of the folks who either
got the vaccine but didn't develop immunity,
couldn't get the vaccine because of medical
condition, and some of them will die.
That's that's the decision of anybody who
could get it and chooses not to.
Is that you are increasing the odds that somebody
dies as a result of your actions.
I'm glad I'm not participating in that.
Other information from the poll approval for
Joe Biden so far is really looking pretty
good, 54 percent approval for Biden.
Remember that Donald Trump never got to 50
percent approval even once during his presidency.
Sixty two percent approval for Joe Biden's
handling of the virus.
That's up from 57 percent in March.
There was the idea that it was up in March,
but it's going to go down as Biden becomes
the new normal.
No covid approval for Biden continuing to
go up for comparison.
Biden at 62, Trump was at 34 percent approval
on covid when he left office and 63 percent
approval for Biden's covid stimulus bill,
which was passed last month.
So the numbers are looking very solid for
Joe Biden.
I think getting infrastructure done would
boost them a little bit, but infrastructure
is less visible to the average person.
And it's also it takes longer than just something
gets passed and then you get fourteen hundred
bucks.
So the impact on approval may be maybe lower.
One last thought, the pause going on right
now on the Johnson and Johnson vaccine, which
we talked about earlier this week, it is giving
a boost to the anti VAX people and it will
be something that we will have to wait and
see the effect of.
We see it impacting people anecdotally saying,
well, now I'm definitely never getting any
vaccine seeing that on social media, that
wasn't yet part of this polling information.
So if we now see a reversal and vaccine hesitancy
goes up, it would be important to look at
whether the pause on the JMJ vaccine is a
factor in that